Je suis Asif Kapadia, je suis le réalisateur d'Amy.
J'ai déjà travaillé avec la même équipe sur
le film Sena. Ce film
est donc vraiment sorti de Centaurus. J'ai presque
dû suivre l'équipe créative, mais
oui, je suis réalisateur.  l'idée de faire
un Mimi est venue vraiment de James le
producteur James a donné à Reese m'a donné une bague
Je me souviens où j'étais Je
rentrais chez moi dans le nord de Londres J'ai
reçu un appel et James Scylla quelqu'un
m'a téléphoné et m'a dit  seriez-vous
intéressé à faire un film à Amy
Winehouse et à l'époque je faisais un
film intitulé L'Odyssée sur les
Jeux olympiques de Londres et donc j'ai passé beaucoup
de temps vraiment pour la première fois à faire
un film sur Londres je '  Je suis assis dans lequel j'ai
grandi et vécu toute ma vie et en
particulier au nord de Londres et je suppose
que c'est là qu'un moi s'est intégré, il a soudainement
eu un sens pour creuser plus profondément dans le monde dans
lequel je vis et où j'ai grandi
et il y a quelques  à propos d'Amy qui est toujours
connectée avec moi, je n'ai jamais vu h  euh la
vie et je n'ai jamais rencontré Amy mais j'aime la
musique j'avais ses disques il y a
quelque chose comme un point d'interrogation que
je n'ai jamais vraiment compris comment les choses
se sont passées comme elles l'ont fait pourquoi se sont-elles
déroulées comme elles l'ont fait et elle
ressemblait à une petite amie  sur la route, elle
m'a juste semblé comme quelqu'un que j'aurais pu
grandir en connaissant, donc c'était un
sentiment instinctif qu'il y avait là une
histoire qui pouvait être racontée et que
c'était comme s'il y avait un film à faire,
il y avait quelque chose à propos d'Amy une fois que je
a commencé à faire un peu de recherche juste sur
Internet sur YouTube,
c'était toujours un drame de manière positive
ou négative, ce n'était jamais
ennuyeux avec elle, elle était drôle ou
quelque chose se
passait autour d'elle, donc c'était un
sentiment instinctif quand James
m'a appelé pour avoir l'impression qu'il y avait un film
là-dedans et c'est quelque chose qui
m'engagerait d'abord en tant que réalisateur à
vouloir en savoir plus sur une histoire mais
aussi pour un public évidemment que je connaissais
elle avait une grande base de fans, évidemment, elle avait
un vrai talent mais je n'avais vraiment aucune idée à
quel point elle était talentueuse, à quel point elle était drôle, à quel point
elle était intelligente et à quel point elle était
brillante musicalement et lyriquement,
je veux dire que son écriture est vraiment la grande
révélation pour moi alors oui  le voyage a
commencé je ne sais pas trois il
y a quatre ans je pense qu'il y a
peut-être trois ans quand James a
rattrapé mon nom est James Gary Je suis
producteur et c'est le premier film que
j'ai fait avec Nassif à travers notre nouvelle
société sur  le coin sur Amy
Winehouse
ça s'appelle Amy sur la vie et l'époque d'
Amy Winehouse J'ai été contacté il y a environ
trois ans par David Joseph qui est à
la tête d'Universal Music au Royaume-Uni, il
était un grand fan du film que nous avons fait Sénat
et il m'a demandé  si je serais intéressé à
faire un long métrage documentaire très honnête à accès complet
sur Amy Winehouse et
évidemment elle qui était son label
Universal Music et Island Records avec
son label donc ils avaient une
relation de longue date avec tous les éléments clés
et ob  Je possédais déjà la musique parce que
vous ne pouvez pas vraiment faire ces films
sans la musique, donc j'ai été automatiquement
intrigué par elle Je n'étais pas un grand
fan de Winehouse avant mais j'étais
évidemment très conscient de l'histoire et
même sans en savoir beaucoup sur le  histoire, j'étais à
peu près sûr qu'il y avait
probablement beaucoup plus que le genre de
gros titres que j'avais lus en passant jusqu'à
ce moment-là, comme tout le monde
dans le pays, je m'appelle Chris King et
je suis l'éditeur d'Amy I  pensez que la chose à
propos d'Amy Winehouse qui m'a attiré
en premier lieu était qu'elle était
une histoire de célébrité tellement moderne et c'était
aussi une histoire de talent et d'où
vient la créativité et la façon dont les
gens qui sont talentueux et très très
créatifs sont  traité et géré par
la culture au sens large de nos jours, il y a tellement
de grandes attentes placées sur les gens
au-delà de la création de leur art de
nos jours à cause de la culture de la célébrité
et je pense qu'elle a été en quelque sorte l'une
des premières victimes o  f que quelqu'un
qui était vraiment créatif, un
artiste qui veut faire quelque chose dans
son cas, la musique aurait pu être la peinture
ou la sculpture ou tout ce
qu'elle voulait faire dans sa vie, mais parce
qu'elle a été déplacée dans un domaine commercial beaucoup plus actuel
et  a fini par être considérée
comme faisant partie de la nouvelle culture des célébrités,
elle n'était pas capable de faire de la musique, donc
la chose même qui a apporté devait avoir la renommée
qu'elle n'a pas pu faire à la fin, ce n'est
que lorsque je suis entré là-bas et que j'ai commencé à
chercher  au matériel avec Asif que
nous avons vu quelle personnalité vibrante incroyable
elle était et a drôle et
charmante et pleine d'esprit et et aussi
apprécié son talent son
talent lyrique ainsi que je pense sera
probablement assez surprenant pour beaucoup
de gens que vous connaissez elle  était
vraiment un talent de classe mondiale et et
l'histoire de la façon dont elle, vous savez, est devenue une
sorte de à un moment donné a été réduite à
être une risée, vous savez qu'il est une
tragédie très moderne, donc c'était le
genre de choses que dr  m'a
invité et m'a encouragé à travailler sur le film
Je pense qu'Amy Winehouse est importante à
plusieurs niveaux, elle est vraiment une
artiste musicale à succès énorme
Je suppose que je suis intéressé par le
personnage Je suis intéressé par la personne
et l'histoire derrière elle  vie très courte
malheureusement courte et ce que nous avons trouvé en
faisant le film, c'est que son histoire parle
à tout le monde tout le monde que j'ai rencontré à
Londres tout le monde est en quelque sorte lié à
elle tout le monde je sais à peu près je l'
ai rencontrée ou je l'ai rencontrée ou
connais quelqu'un qui la connaissait, donc ça ressemble
à une histoire pertinente pour tout le monde dans
la ville, mais aussi quand vous allez à l'
international, tout le monde a une opinion
c'est intéressant avec quand nous
faisions Senna, il y avait des gens qui étaient de
vrais fans inconditionnels de Senna et il
y a d'autres personnes  qui n'avait vraiment jamais
entendu parler de lui et j'avais l'impression d'avoir
toujours affaire à ces deux
groupes de personnes différents, des gens qui connaissaient le
pilote de course et des gens qui n'avaient jamais
entendu parler d'un homme avec A  mon il est très difficile
de trouver quelqu'un qui n'a jamais entendu parler d'elle
tout le monde la connaît donc vous êtes et
ils pensent qu'ils connaissent son histoire Je pense que
ce qui est intéressant à son sujet, c'est que
c'est un conte de moralité si moderne si vous
aimez je veux dire que Senna était un  une sorte d'
histoire inspirante a eu lieu il y a environ 20
ans et c'est vraiment à propos d'un
homme que vous savez en quelque sorte vouloir être le
meilleur possible et vous savez qu'en
fin de compte c'est une sorte de fable d'Icare
vous savez que c'est à propos d'un gars qui vole trop
près  au soleil et évidemment vous savez qu'il
brûle les ailes, mais cela semblait différent
même si elle est une jeune figure emblématique,
il était une figure emblématique plus jeune, ils sont tous les deux
morts jeunes, c'est un type
de voyage très différent et un type de film très différent
, vous savez fondamentalement je '  m c'est
une histoire très moderne, il s'agit des périls
de l'argent de la liberté de la renommée au 21e
siècle et vous savez que j'ai toujours été
attiré par cela et que je suis devenu de plus en plus attiré par
cela lorsque nous approfondissions
le sujet parce que c'était  est venu assez
clairement qu'Amy n'était pas nécessairement
intéressée par la célébrité ou l'argent ou l'un
de ces signes extérieurs, vous savez, les signes extérieurs du 21e siècle
auxquels tant de gens
aspirent et cela en soi est assez
rafraîchissant,
mais elle se sentait très aliénée par sa renommée
et  la célébrité et vous savez ne pouvait pas y
échapper et nous, vous savez, nous étions à certains
égards autodestructeurs à son égard, vous
savez qu'elle ne l'attraperait pas, en fait,
elle ferait tout son possible pour le
combattre pour ainsi dire, ce qui  évidemment, vous savez que cela
a fait des ravages, mais il y avait juste
quelque chose dans son histoire qui, à mon avis,
était très pertinent pour la façon dont nous vivons maintenant
et vous savez que tout le monde est différent
évidemment, mais c'est juste avec le genre de
fascination continue pour la célébrité dans
ce pays et dans l'Ouest  monde en
particulier, il semblait juste de mettre en
lumière les pièges potentiels
de ce voyage, vous savez,
car peu de gens peuvent y faire face
et je pense que c'est avoir de jeunes enfants, c'est
très intéressant, vous savez, parce que
ils sont tellement obsédés par les célébrités et le
genre de vous connaissez assez souvent des
célébrités assez vides de sens et il essaie de leur
inculquer que c'est vous savez que ce n'est
en aucun cas l'alpha et l'oméga, je
pense que malheureusement l'histoire d'Amy
va vraiment montrer  que vous savez que tout n'est pas à l'
envers en fait il n'y a qu'un très petit
pourcentage de ce type de voyage qui
n'est pas ce qui est bon à l'envers
il y a toujours un problème narratif Lee
comment faites-vous un film lorsque vous
utilisez essentiellement des images que vous trouvez
ou  j'espère pouvoir saisir donc il y a
eu des difficultés créatives il y a
eu des sortes de difficultés techniques mais
aussi ça a été des difficultés assez émotionnelles et
psychologiques de
raconter une vraie histoire personnelle c'est assez
douloureux c'est assez difficile il y a de
vraies personnes là-bas qui  sont affectés
par ce que vous dites dans le film et c'est
vraiment là que les documentaires et les drames
me semblent différents avec un drame vous pouvez
faire ou dire ce que vous voulez ce sont des
acteurs  ils font semblant et peu importe
la puissance d'un film, vous savez que
ce n'est pas une vraie personne qui meurt à l'écran
et comme ce que nous avons avec Amy, nous avons
quelqu'un qui est très malade et qui a des
problèmes et vous voyez que cela arrive à une vraie
personne et  les gens autour d'elle et
connectés à elle, donc cela apporte toujours des
difficultés et des défis et je
suppose que oui, cela a été tout un
défi d'essayer d'obtenir la confiance des
gens et pour eux de rester avec nous dans
un voyage afin que nous puissions raconter
l'histoire ainsi  d'une manière ou d'une autre, une
forme de vérité ressort de la
réalisation du film et donc je pense que
beaucoup de gens ont ressenti cela à son sujet,
beaucoup de gens ont estimé qu'ils la connaissaient
mieux que quiconque et
donc c'était un  défi d'
essayer définitivement de concilier tous ces différents
points de vue sur elle parce qu'ils sont
tous totalement valables, mais c'est notre travail en tant que
cinéastes d'essayer de nous frayer un chemin à
travers tous ces
points de vue parfois légèrement contrastés ou Na  mie et
elle était un être humain très compliqué,
il n'y a aucun doute là-dessus quand
elle était vraiment très compliquée,
intelligente de manière crédible mais très stratifiée et donc essayer de
vraiment traverser toutes ces couches était
un défi,
donc les interviews à bien des égards ont formé
l'histoire de la  film et ensuite nous
recherchions des images qui visualiseraient d'une manière ou d'une autre
l'histoire c'était un
processus très inhabituel Je n'ai pas vraiment travaillé de
cette façon avant
cela semblait unique à cette histoire parce que les
gens étaient la plupart des gens à qui j'ai
parlé et non donné  une interview avant et
ce n'était pas vraiment comme une interview pour un
film, c'était littéralement les gens qui
recevaient toutes ces informations et ces
poids qui les portaient secrètement
hors de leur esprit et de leur dos et
et à la fin de leur beaucoup de larmes
beaucoup de gens qui ont pleuré pendant le
processus étaient assez émotifs et tout était
comme je l'ai dit, c'était presque comme un
processus de thérapie dont il
a été guéri,
je ne pouvais en fait pas  mettre un chiffre
sur la quantité de matériel que nous avons fini par
avoir pour ce film, c'est probablement des
milliers d'heures et ça continue à
arriver ce n'était pas une inondation en fait ça
coulait je veux dire il y a beaucoup de
choses là-bas parce qu'elle est arrivée
ce genre de chaleur le grand moment de la
culture des célébrités, donc chaque pas qu'elle
a fait pendant un moment a été filmé par quelqu'un
ou plutôt elle ne pouvait pas sortir de sa
porte d'entrée sans que quelqu'un la
suive jusqu'au magasin du coin jusqu'à sa
maison partout  elle y est allée, il y avait des
voitures de poursuite qui la suivaient sur la route,
donc inévitablement, il y a des centaines et des
centaines d'heures juste qu'elle a vécu une
partie de sa vie dans le genre d'
épicentre absolu de la culture des célébrités, donc
chaque pas a été poursuivi par les paparazzi
et par les vidéastes  donc il y avait des
centaines et des centaines d'heures de juste
sa promenade dans le magasin du coin entrer dans
la friterie marcher jusqu'à la chèvre au curry en
revenant aller dans les bars en
revenant de je veux dire jus  t
chaque partie de sa vie avait été couverte
et toutes ses performances également,
puis nous sommes entrés dans le matériel le plus
intrigant qui était des gens qui avaient passé du
temps avec elle qui filmeraient également le matériel personnel
de  des trucs et il y avait beaucoup de
matériel connexe ainsi que des choses qui
ont été filmées par d'autres personnes qui étaient en
quelque sorte autour de l'histoire la plus mortelle
et il avait quelques morceaux qui étaient
très intéressants de ses propres expériences
d'être poursuivi et attaqué par des
paparazzi donc  Je veux dire que nous avons fini par regarder,
je ne sais pas, c'était des mois et des mois
et des mois à regarder et
à rassembler lentement une soif en
assemblant une première coupe du film
, puis vous savez aussi longtemps pour
en faire un film  comme vous
pouvez le voir maintenant,
la principale différence est vraiment que certaines d'entre
elles sont anglaises et donc tous les
acteurs clés de l'histoire ici et c'est une
histoire très familière d'abord, je connaissais un peu le
Sénat quatre que nous avons commencé à faire
mais c'était il y a 20 ans
et c'était beaucoup plus éloigné, cela se
sentait très récent et malheureusement Amy
n'est décédée qu'il y a quelques années deux il y a trois
ans, c'est donc l'autre chose qui
a semblé très travaillée pour beaucoup de gens, je
pense que la plus grande différence  entre Amy
et couper Senna était la
séquence de caméra bancale avec le Père Noël, nous avions pas mal
de choses qui étaient en fait
assez bien cadrées dans InFocus pendant plus d'
une seconde diffusion alors que dans ce film,
nous devions faire face à une grande
quantité de choses intéressantes qui étaient  tourné par des gens
qui n'avaient jamais pris un appareil photo de leur
vie auparavant et qui le tenaient dans
une main et marchaient sur une route avec une
pinte dans l'autre main et c'est une
séquence captivante mais ce n'est pas la
séquence cinématographique la plus attrayante
alors qu'à Senna  nous avions des griffonnages de
matériel de film vraiment magnifique et de
matériel HD et de plans d'hélicoptère et
toutes sortes de choses
s'il y a un seul message à tirer
de ce film, c'est que nous  collectivement, en
tant que public mondial et culture mondiale, nous
devons nous soucier de ces
individus très créatifs qui nous donnent ces
choses que nous apprécions tous, l'art et
les choses culturelles que nous apprécions tous, nous
devons nous occuper d'eux, nous devons nous
assurer qu'ils sont capables  continuer à
faire cela et ne pas être absorbé par la
culture des célébrités et par le besoin
de réponses rapides et instantanées et d'avoir accès
à chaque mouvement des gens tout le
temps, les
gens ont besoin d'une vie privée simplement
parce que quelqu'un fait quelque chose de créatif,
cela ne veut pas dire que  ils doivent également partager
chaque partie de leur
vie personnelle parce que je pense que c'était un
énorme problème pour Amy et cela n'aurait pas
dû être là en premier lieu, elle
aurait dû être soignée et
vénérée et ce n'est que maintenant que nous '  en la
regardant en arrière, nous pouvons voir que les
gens auraient dû savoir qu'à l'
époque et à l'avenir, nous devrions savoir que je
sais ce que j'aimerais vraiment que les gens
sortent leurs films j'aimerais que les gens
re  évaluer à Amy Winehouse parce que je
pense que nous avons fait un travail très réussi
dans ce pays en la brutalisant
ainsi que les médias tabloïds grand public, elle
est devenue une cible facile que les gens utilisent, il y
avait un sac de frappe qui parlait de manière totalement inappropriée
de quelqu'un que vous connaissez avec des
problèmes de santé mentale qui vous  know avait du
mal et je pense que beaucoup de
gens le savaient mais ont choisi de l'ignorer
et je pense que c'est juste que si ce
film empêche les médias de traiter les
gens comme ça à l'avenir, ce
serait parce que ça n'arrêtera pas ça mais
si  cela a fait réfléchir certaines personnes à deux fois avant de
le refaire à l'avenir Je pense
que ce serait un exploit J'espère
que les gens pour commencer il y a beaucoup de
gens que j'ai rencontrés au début du
processus qui m'ont dit pourquoi tu veux
faire un film sur un junkie qui s'en
fout de junkie et je me souviens avoir eu l'impression
d'être wow c'est intéressant que vous
ayez un jeune qui même si ces
gens sont vraiment intelligents et
bien éduqués  ils se sont toujours forgé une
opinion à partir des tabloïds même s'ils n'ont pas l'
impression de lire des tabloïds les tabloïds
ont aidé à se forger une opinion sur un
être humain et ils ne se sont jamais rencontrés et c'est
devenu comme un voyage pour dire
révélons qui est vraiment ce jeune  était à
quel point ils étaient brillants et à quel point
ils n'auraient pas été intelligents et
personne n'a commencé à vouloir
être une drogue, vous savez, accro à la drogue est
accro à l'alcool ou quelles que soient ses
circonstances qui les emmènent sur une
certaine voie, alors je suis  en espérant que le film
fera un peu un point en
dévoilant tout d'abord comment elle est
représentée et que les gens réévalueront
Amy mais aussi d'autres personnes qui sont
maltraitées par les médias ou qui, en quelque sorte,
vous savez qu'elles peuvent simplement être choisies pour  étant
vous le savez aux yeux du public, j'espère
que d'une manière ou d'une autre, le film traitera
de certains de ces problèmes, mais
j'espère principalement que cela fera penser aux gens qu'il
y a beaucoup de problèmes de type
dépression comme l'alcoolisme comme addictif
il y a beaucoup de problèmes traités dans le
film et je pense que tout le monde a quelqu'un
dans sa famille qui a traité cela
ou a eu un problème à ce sujet et peut-être que nous
n'en parlons pas et peut-être que cela,
je l'espère, lancera un débat un  filmer
quelque part